hello welcome to the Library of Congress
the library Congress is the largest
library in the world located in
Washington DC this collection of over
160 million items is of that archive of
the history of the United States there
are over 70 special collections that
include rare manuscripts Maps sheet
music and much more hello I'm Helena's
ink hemp director for collections and
also chief of the prints and photographs
division with collection of pictures
numbers more than 15 million among the
rarest pictures in our collection we
have the migrant mother the iconic woman
representing the entire Great Depression
the pictures bring people together they
invite you in to look around and explore
world that you might never be able to
see in person
hello I am Paulette hazier I am the
chief of the geography of math division
we have five point five million map
these thousand atlases five hundred
globe we have Lewis and Clark's map
George Washington's maps we have the
first map that shows the name America
we're part of the bigger broader world
and as we look at some of these
photographic evidence of the changes
over time it's a realization that we as
a nation have changed over hi I'm sue
Vita the chief of the music division
there are about 24 million items in the
music collections we have Stradivari
instruments we have the original
rhapsody in blue the original edition of
the star-spangled banner' music tells us
more about who we are and tells us about
our past in our future
[Music]
hi my name is Michael North and I'm head
of reference and reader services in the
rare book and special collections
division at the Library of Congress this
collection holds over a hundred thousand
items we have everything from medieval
manuscripts early printed books the
library of Thomas Jefferson one of our
most famous books is the Gutenberg Bible
it's important to have a record of the
past so that we know how we came to be
where we are today both in terms of
ideas and in terms of history politics
arts everything hi I'm Malia Walker I'm
a reference librarian in the serial on
government publications division this
collection is massive we have eight
hundred thousand reels of microfilm
we have about 7.2 million loose issues
of newspapers and approximately 42,000
volumes of balanced newspaper pages we
also have about one hundred and forty
thousand issues of comic books one of
the great things about reading
newspapers is that you get a sense of
what it's like to be an American you are
reading how people lived the history
itself collection are a way of adding
memory and remembrance all of the
collections give meaning and context to
the human experience
and a history of culture
Oh